el equipo de rescate de emergencia que
trabaja aquí en yablé en el norte de
Siria es ruso el Ministerio de
situaciones de emergencia de Rusia ha
enviado a más de 50 personas además de
tres equipos con perros para ayudar a
Damasco en sus esfuerzos de recuperación
tras los terremotos
lo más difícil es que hay losas de
concreto colgando estamos trabajando con
mucho cuidado continuamos removiendo
escombros con la esperanza de que haya
áreas vacías donde todavía encontremos
personas vivas
según medios sirios 300.000 personas se
han visto obligadas a abandonar sus
hogares debido a la catástrofe otros
países que ayudan a Siria incluyen a
Irán y su ayuda se está descargando en
el aeropuerto de alepo siendo uno de los
varios países que colaboran con Damasco
y que incluyen a los emiratos árabes
Unidos Irak y Argelia sin embargo los
que se oponen al régimen de vallar al
azar no confían en Damasco para obtener
ayuda en las áreas de oposición las
autoridades responsables del paso
fronterizo baba aseguran que no ha
entrado ayuda humanitaria a la región
desde que sucedió el sismo La media luna
roja árabe Siria dice que esta lista
para entregar ayuda humanitaria a Siria
a todas las áreas afectadas por el
terremoto incluidas aquellas que no
están bajo el control del gobierno y
piden que se levanten las sanciones a la
luz de la destrucción masiva
La media luna roja y otros están
pidiendo a la comunidad internacional
incluida la Unión Europea que levante
las sanciones económicas contra Siria
la Unión Europea y los Estados Unidos
tienen exenciones previstas a las
sanciones por ayuda humanitaria pero
Bruselas dice que Damasco aún no ha
solicitado formalmente activar este
mecanismo Washington está enviando ayuda
a Turquía y dice que hará lo mismo en
Siria a través de las ong sobre el
terreno el lugar de entregarla al
gobierno Mientras tanto en ambas partes
del norte de Siria los trabajadores de
emergencia locales controlados por el
gobierno y la oposición dicen que la
asistencia es limitada